CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
[inaudible]
DODD.
YOUR DIED HERE WILK PRESIDENT
WILL CARE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCH LETTER HERE PORGES.
OR JUST HERE BRADFORD.
CHANGE.
GALGIANI GLAZER.
GLAZER HERE HILL.
HILL HERE WEST SO JONES.
JONES HERE NIELSEN [inaudible]
TINO.
PORTANTINO HERE RUBIO.
RUBIO AS A RUBIO HERE WIENER.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM OF FIRST
ORDER BUSINESS MORNING'S ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB TWO SIXTY FOUR BY
CENTER GLAZER [inaudible]
GLAZER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THERE'S A LOT OF
TECHNICAL ISSUES IN OUR WORLD
AND CERTAINLY YOU'RE GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT ONE ON THIS BILL SO I
WILL WALK YOU THROUGH -- THE
PURPOSE OF IT BUT THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW A TYPE TWO WINE
GROWERS LICENSEE. TO HAVE UP TO
TWO OFFSITE TASTING ROOMS.
UNDER EXISTING LAW TYPE TWO
WINERIES ARE ALLOWED UP TO TWO
TASTING ROOMS TOTAL ONE ON SITE
AT THEIR PRODUCTION FACILITY.
AND A SECOND OFF SITE.
I HAVE A OVER -- FIFTY FIVE ONE
REASON MY DISTRICTS HAVE BETWEEN
THE LIVERMORE VALLEY IN EAST
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
AND A YEAR OR SO AGO WHEN TORY
MY DISTRICTS AGRICULTURE ON WINE
REGION IT WAS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION THAT AN ISSUE ARISES
FOR SOME WINERIES.
WHEN THEY OPERATE UNTRUE AND
UNDER AN ALTAR ALTERNATING
PROPRIETORSHIP?
AN AGREEMENT WHERE WINERY IT
WILL PRODUCE THEIR WINE AT
ANOTHER WINERIES PRODUCTION
FACILITY.
WHEN A WINERY ENTERS INTO THIS
AGREEMENT?
THERE ARE MASTER TYPE TO WINE
GROWERS LICENSE AND THE
ACCOMPANYING RIGHT TO AN ON SITE
TASTING ROOM IS USED TO COVER
THE BORROWED FACILITY.
WITH SOME RARE EXCEPTIONS THAT
MEANS IN PRACTICE THAT WINERIES
OPERATING UNDER THESE AGREEMENTS.
ARE REQUIRED TO OBTAIN AND USE
IT TO DUPLICATE TYPE TO WINE
GROWERS LICENSE FOR THEIR
INITIAL TASTING ROOM.
AND AS A RESULT ARE UNABLE TO
HAVE TO STE TASTING ROOMS LIKE
MOST OTHER TYPE TWO WINERIES. TO
ADDRESS THIS DISPARITY THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW ALL TIED TO WINE
GROWERS TO HAVE TWO TASTING
ROOMS WHILE MAINTAINING THE
EXISTING PRIVILEGES FOR WINERIES
WHEN VESTED THEIR PRODUCTION
EQUIPMENT.
IMPORTANTLY ANY ADDITIONAL
OFFSITE TASTING ROOM THAT WOULD
BE AUTHORIZED UNDER THIS BILL
WOULD NEED TO MEET EXISTING
LOCALZONING REQUIREMENTS.
AND WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURES TIM
SCHMELZER WITH THE WINE
INSTITUTE.
pWINE INSTITUTE -- HERE TO
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION -- TASTING ROOMS ARE
OFTEN THE ONLY OPPORTUNITY FOR
SMALLER WINERIES TO CONNECT WITH
THEIR CUSTOMERS -- THE EXPANSION
OF THIS PRIVILEGE TO ALLOW FOR
ANOTHER ROOM -- WILL GREATLY
ENHANCE THEIR OPPORTUNITY
BUSINESS AND CONNECT WITH
CALIFORNIANS.
KIRCHER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE'S SUPPORT ANY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE TURN BACK -- TO
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
THIS.
THANK YOU JUST A QUICK QUESTION.
WHAT WAS THE RATIONALE OR DO YOU
ARE YOU AWARE OF THE RATIONALE
THAT LIMITED TO ONE IN NOT?
THREE FOUR WELL IT IT THEIR
EXISTING LAW ALLOWED YOU TO HAVE
TO BUT A MONTH WHAT YOU'D HAVE
TO HAVE TO WHICH ONE COULD BE
WHERE YOU'RE WE PRODUCE THE WINE.
AND THE SECOND WHERE YOU WANT TO
HAVE YOUR TASTING ROOM SAY AND
MARK -- CONVENIENT LOCATION FOR
VISITORS -- BECAUSE WINERIES
DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT THAT THE
CAPITAL TO HAVE ALL THEIR
PRODUCTION IN HOUSE.
THAT THEY THEY CONTRACTED OUT
FOR THAT PRODUCTION ADD ANOTHER
WINERY SPACE SO THEY COULDN'T
HAVE THAT THEY COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF EXISTING LAW TO
HAVE A TASTE ROOM AT SOMEONE
ELSE'S SPACE.
SO THAT'S KIND OF THE SITUATION
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE IS
THAT THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN ALLOWED.
TO BUT THEY WERE THEY DEFINE ONE
OF THEM TO BE WHERE YOU PRODUCED
AND IN THIS CASE WHEN YOU'RE
SMALL YOU DON'T NESTLE HAVE ALL
THE EQUIPMENT TO PRODUCE AN AT
AND HOUSE.
ALLOWING YOU TO HAVE TO LIKE
OTHER WINERIES SO THIS WOULD
GIVE THEM THAT EXTRA PRIVILEGE
OUT BECAUSE OUR SMALL.
I'D OF A SPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IF WE A MOTION BY SENATOR HILL --
TO TO PASS -- THIS THIS BILL --
WE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE FILE
ITEM TO SB TWO SIX FOUR MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD.
HI.
DODD HI WELCOME HI WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES OR BORDERS
AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO.
JONES.
JONES I NIELSEN.
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
[inaudible]
I WIENER. ELEVEN WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR THAT -- HAS ELEVEN ON
THE STRENGTH OF THAT WONDERFUL
CLOTHES THAT I'D NEVER ALLOWED
YOU TO GIVE -- WITH THAT -- WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN THANK SENATOR.
WE'RE GONNA DO -- GOING -- TO
COUPLE BILLS I'M RUNNING SO --
ITEM NUMBER THREE WILL BE FIRST
SB
.
TWO NINETY HI.
I KNOW YOU REMOVED REMEMBER THAT
FOREVER
.
MISTER CHAIR YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CLIMATE CHANGE IS
CREATING ENORMOUS FINANCIAL RISK
AND CHALLENGES FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
LAST YEAR MORE THAN SIX THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL FIRES BROKE OUT
THROUGHOUT THE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA BURNING EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND ACRES
DESTROYING HOMES AND TRAGICALLY
KILLING.
A HUNDRED FOR PEOPLE.
WHILE FAR DESTRUCTION RESULTING
INSURED LOSSES OF OVER TWENTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
CALIFORNIA'S SPENT OVER NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON WILD FIRE SUPPRESSION
IN EMERGENCY RESPONSE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN
EXCEEDING ARE EXPECTED BUDGET.
BY OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN ADDITION THE SUPPRESSION IN
RESPONSE COST.
THE STATE IS SPENDING BILLIONS
MORE ON RECOVERY.
THIS FINANCIAL STRESS LEADS THE
BUDGET INSTABILITY.
THIS INSTABILITY IS BECOME
TYPICAL RATHER THAN OCCASIONAL.
OUR STATE BUDGET IS BEING
IMPACTED FOR YEARS TO COME.
UNEXPECTED DISASTERS CREATE
EXTREME BUDGET UNCERTAINTY
TAKING AWAY RESOURCES FROM OTHER
VITAL SERVICES AND REDUCING OUR
ABILITY TO PROTECT AGAINST OR
PREVENT FUTURE DISASTERS. TO
CORRECT THAT.
SB TWO NINETY IS A PLAN THAT
BRINGS GREATER PREDICTABILITY TO
OUR STATE COFFERS IN TIMES OF
DISASTER.
IT ALLOWS US. TO FIND MORE STATE
SERVICES OR MAKE GREATER
INVESTMENTS IN WILDFIRE
PREVENTION.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA'S ACTOR
DISASTER INSURANCE ACT SB TWO
NINETY THE THE GOVERNOR WORKING
WITH THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
AND THE TREASURER IS AUTHORIZED
TO NEGOTIATE ENTER INTO.
AN INSURANCE POLICY THAT PAYS
OUT WHEN WE HAVE UNEXPECTED
DISASTER EXPENSES.
SIMPLY PUT.
THIS IS INSURANCE ON A SPECIFIC
PORTION OF OUR STATE BUDGET THAT
LETS US HARNESS INSURANCE
MARKETS TO STABILIZE THE STATE
WILDFIRE BUDGETS.
IN FREE UP RESOURCES FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION.
WE WOULD NOT BE THE FIRST STATE
TO EMBARK ON SUCH A RIG --
COURSE OF REDUCTION RISK
REDUCTION THROUGH INSURANCE THE
STATE OF OREGON HAS BEEN USING
INSURANCE ON WILDFIRE FUNDS FOR
THE PAST FORTY YEARS.
THE STATE WOULD ONLY SECURE
INSURANCE.
ON TERMS THAT BENEFIT TAXPAYERS
LET ME REPEAT THAT THE STATE
WOULD ONLY SECURE INSURANCE ON
TERMS THAT WOULD BENEFIT%
TAXPAYERS.
SB TWO NINETY IS SUPPORTED BY
OUR TREASURE WHO'S HERE WITH ME
TODAY THE AUDIBLE FIELD AMAT.
AS WELL AS INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THE RBEL RICARDO
LARA REPRESENTED TODAY BY DEPUTY
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER MICHAEL
MARTINEZ.
THANK YOU A SENATOR DODD AND
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND TO MEMBERS IT'S NICE TO
BE.
UP BACK -- INVOLVED THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS -- I THINK
WE ALL HAVE SEEN THAT -- FIRES
AND FLOODS -- IT'S NOT A MATTER
OF WITH IF BUT WHEN AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO BE
PROACTIVE INSTEAD OF REACTIVE.
IN THIS AREA SO YOU THE THREE
MAIN TAKEAWAYS OUT FOR THIS BILL
THIS BILL IS PERMISSIVE NOT
PRESCRIPTIVE.
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT THAT THE
STATE TO ANYTHING JUST
ESTABLISHES THE REQUIREMENT THAT
IT MAY DO SOMETHING UNDER THE
RIGHT SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES.
NUMBER TWO THE STATE'S RESPONSE
TO WILDFIRE SHOULD BE SEEN AS A
CONTINUUM NOT AS A SINGLE
LEGISLATIVE ACT.
RESPONSES ARE INTENTIONAL
INTERCONNECTED AND BECOME PART
OF A LARGER WHOLE PROBABLY THE
LARGER HOLE THAT THE GOVERNOR
STRIKE FORCE IS.
UNDOUBTABLY CONTEMPLATING AND
THREE THE STATE'S CURRENT
FINANCIAL SURPLUSES ARE NOT A
FUTURE GIVEN RATHER ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT FLEXIBILITY IS OFFERED
BY SB.
TWO NINETY IS WHEN ABLE FUTURE
FINANCIAL BURDENS TO BE INSURED
IN THE FUTURE.
IF IT IS IN THE STATE'S BEST
INTEREST TO DO SO AND BY DOING
SO THE STATE'S FINANCIAL
CONDITION AND RECEPTION.
IN THE DEBT MARKETS IS PROTECTED
IN TIMES OF FISCAL STRESS.
IN AS SENATOR DODD MENTIONED --
YOU'RE NOT THE FIRST STATE TO DO
THIS -- ORGAN HAS HAD A LONG
STANDING WILDFIRE POLICY -- AND
THEY BY COVERAGE THAT LAST FORTY
YEARS.
OF THE WORLD BANK HAS A
CATASTROPHE BOND TO HELP WITH
EARTHQUAKES AROUND THE WORLD.
AND THEN FEMA ALSO HAS INSURANCE
THAT PROTECTS US STATES AGAINST
FLOOD INSURANCE SO.
ON THIS IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT
JUST LIKE WE BUY HEALTH
INSURANCEAND HOME INSURANCE AND
CAR INSURANCE AT THE SAME
CONCEPT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HI GOOD MORNING MICHAEL MARTINEZ
SENIOR DEPUTY INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE HERE.
ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RECORD A LOT OF
SENSES REGRETS NOT BEING ABLE TO
BE HERE HE IS CURRENTLY OUT OF
THE STATE.
AND I HAVE HERE WITH ME MIKE
PETERSON WHO SERVES AS THE
COMMISSIONERS NEW INAUGURAL
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER FOR CLIMB
AND SUSTAINABILITY TO HELP
PROVIDE US SOME REMARKS MUTUALLY
AFTER ME.
SO FOR THOSE OF YOU REMEMBER IT
THEN CENTER LOT I WHEN HE WAS
HERE IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER HIS STRONG
PASSION.
FOR COMBATING CLIMATE CHANGE
WHEN HE WAS HERE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND SO HE STRONGLY
BELIEVES THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS
CURRENT CONTRIBUTING TO MORE
SEVERE WILD FIRES AND VOLATILE
COSTS FOR THE STATE.
WE SEE THIS INSURANCE MARKETS
WITH LOSSES TOTALING OVER TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS AS A RESULT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND THAT THESE CONTINUAL CLIMATE
RESTORED REALLY CHALLENGING US
TO RETHINK.
HOW WE PROTECT OUR STATE BUDGET
FROM ALL FIRE SHOCKS INCLUDING
HOW TO HARNESS PRUDENT INSURANCE
PRODUCTS USED ALREADY THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD?
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE OUR
BUDGETS PREDICTABILITY AND
EMPOWER THE STATE TO INVEST IN
GREATER RISK REDUCTION EFFORTS
WITHOUT NEEDING TO DROP ON THE
STATE'S.
BUDGET RESERVES AND AS THE THE
THE TREASURED STATED THAT THIS
IS A AGAIN PERMISSIVE IT ALLOWS
US WITH THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY
THE FROM THE GOVERNOR.
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND STATE
TREASURER TO EXPLORE THIS OPTION
TO MAKE SURE IT'S AN BENEFIT TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IN
ONE THING.
TO OF CHAIR DOT FOR HS
AUTHORSHIP OF THIS MEASURE AND
AND FOR COOPER -- CO SPONSORSHIP
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE TREASURE
MIKE.
THE MORNING OF MY PEERS AND AND
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE -- SO I
JUST WANTED A COUPLE NOTES ON
THE FEMALE EXAMPLE HISTORICALLY
FEMA'S NATIONAL FLOOD INSURANCE
PROGRAM HAS HELD RESERVES TO
RESPOND TO LARGE SCALE STORMS.
IN COULD YEARS USERS OR STAY PUT
AND THEY LOOK LIKE A STRONG
POLICY BUT THEN THERE ARE
CHALLENGING YEARS SO IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE WHEN HURRICANE
KATRINA HIT.
ON THE COSTA SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWELVE WHEN
SUPERSTORM SANDY HIT THE
NORTHEAST THE COST WITH EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS CAUSED VEHEMENTLY CONSIDER
OTHER STRATEGIES BETTER POSITION
AGENCY TO RESPOND TO FLOODS
WITHOUT OVER ANY RESERVES. SEVEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FEMA BEGIN
SECURING REINSURANCE ON THEIR
FLOOD RESPONSE FUNDS.
THE POLICY WAS SET UP THIS WAY
THE POLICY WOULD TRIGGER IF
TOTAL LOSSES REACHED FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN WHICH CASE
FEMA RECEIVES UP TO BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL COVERAGE.
ONE YEAR LATER HURRICANE HARVEY
TRIGGERED THE POLICY AND THE FOR
INSURANCE PROGRAM RECEIVE THE
FULL COVERAGE -- SO WITH THAT SO
AN EXAMPLE ON THE NATIONAL LEVEL
AND THE TREASURE.
TALKED ABOUT THE EXAMPLE ORGAN
ON THE STATE LEVEL WITH A FEW
OTHER EXAMPLES TO THE WORLD BANK
FOR WHAT ALL THESE EXAMPLES HAVE
IN COMMON IS THAT THEY ARE A
MECHANISM TO DIVERSIFY RISK.
AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE DISASTROUS
YOU CAN EITHER SELF INSURE YOU
CAN RELY ON PREVENTION OR YOU
CAN TRANSFER SOME OF THIS RISK
AND THE BASIC ARGUMENT FOR
INSURANCE IS THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
HIGHLY VARIABLE COST YOU CAN
SOME OF THE BUDGET.
BY STRATEGICALLY TRANSFERRING
RISK WHICH IS WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE GOVERNOR
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND
TREASURE TO EXAMINE HAS A POLICY
TO BETTER POSITION CALIFORNIA.
THANKS FOR ALLOWING US TO SPEAK
FOR YOU AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE HONESTY.
TO NINETY SECURE MEMBER SHANE
LEVINE ON BEHALF OF THE RE
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO
NINETY SB TWO NINETY WILL ALLOW
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
AUTHORITY TO CONVERT UNKNOWN
NATURAL DISASTER RESPONSE COSTS
INTO A MANAGEABLE BUDGET ITEM.
THAT ENSURES THE CALIFORNIA WILL
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE NATURAL
DISASTER EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
MAINTAIN ITS OTHER BUDGET
PRIORITIES.
SIMPLY PUT REINSURANCE IS
INSURANCE THAT IS SOLD TO AN
INSURER OR A STATE ENTITY TO
TRANSFER RISK TO LIMIT THE
PROBABILITY OF A LARGER THAN
EXPECTED LOSS OR COSTS.
FROM IN THIS CASE A COVERED
NATURAL DISASTER.
THIS IS A FISCALLY PRUDENT WAY
FOR THE STATE TO MANAGE ITS
DISASTER RIGHT RISK LIKE THE WAY
FOR HIM IN THE STATE OF OREGON
CURRENTLY DO.
COMPARED BORROWING OR BONDING
INSURANCE TRANSFERS A FINANCIAL
RISK OF AN ON CERTAIN AMOUNT FOR
A CERTAIN PREMIUM PAYMENT
INSURANCE DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
STATE TO BORROW NEW MONEY.
IN KERR INTEREST OR REPAY ANY
PRINCIPLE.
DESPITE LARGE LOSSES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REINSURANCE PRICES AND OTHER
TERMS CONTINUE TO BE FAVORABLE
BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF
REINSURANCE CAPITAL EXCEEDS THE
DEMAND FOR REINSURANCE.
BRIEFLY PRICE RISK THEY'RE STILL
INCREDIBLY ROBUST REINSURANCE
MARKET WAS REINSURER CAPITAL
SITTING AT FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS CURRENTLY
AND READY TO BE DEPLOYED.
WE THINK IT MAKES SENSE GIVEN
THE PROBABILITY OF FUTURE
DISASTERS AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE THIS TOOL AT ITS
DISPOSAL WITH THAT WE HAVE
TROUBLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE ANY
OTHERS WANT TO ADD ON GERMAN
MEMBERS JOHN NOR WHEN I'LL BE
OUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA INSURANCE
WHOLESALERS ASSOCIATION.
JUST WANT TO ADD OUR VOICE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN OUR MONTHLY SHOT ON
BEHALF THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
RIGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SIGNALS PULL BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
OKAY THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED --
MISTER CHAIR YOU MAY CLOSE.
SB TWO NINETY PUTS ANOTHER TOOL
IN THE STATE'S TOOL BAG TO
MANAGE STATE RESOURCES IN THE
FACE OF GROWING THREAT OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BUT CLARK.
READ THE ROLE WHILE ITEM THREE
SB TWO NINETY MOTION IS TO PASS
TO RULES COMMITTEE DODD.
I THOUGHT I WILK HI WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HIGH BARGES.
BARGES I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI [inaudible]
CHANGE.
I GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO.
WITH SO I JONES JONES I NIELSEN.
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER. THIRTEEN HOLD
IT OPEN.
CONGRATULATIONS MISTER CHAIR
PAST THIRTEEN OH IS IN NOW MOVE
ON TO RULES COMMITTEE WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER ONE SB.
TWO OH NINE HEY MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AS B. TWO OH NINE WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE WARNING CENTER A JOINT
VENTURE OF THE CPUC.
CAL -- WE US IN CALIFORNIA TO
CONDUCT FIRE WEATHER FORECASTING
THAT ALLOWS FOR ACCURATE
LOCALIZED WILD FIRE RISK
ASSESSMENT.
AND THREAT WARNING.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE WILD
CARD CHALLENGE IN CALIFORNIA IT
IS NECESSARY TO DEVELOP BETTER
WHILE FAR FORECASTING AND WILD
FOR FIRE THREAT ASSESSMENT
CAPABILITIES.
THERE ARE SEVERAL MAJOR
DEFICIENCIES WITH THE CURRENT
STATE OF FIRE WEATHER MONITORING
AND FIRE THREAT RISK ASSESSMENT
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S A LACK OF CRITICAL
WEATHER DATA ESPECIALLY
LOCALIZED WIND DATA.
THERE'S A LACK OF STATE LEVEL
COORDINATION IN THE DEPLOYMENT A
WEATHER STATIONS BY UTILITIES.
THERE'S A LACK OF AGGREGATION OF
WEATHER STATION NETWORK DATA.
THERE'S A LACK OF STATEWIDE FIRE
THREAT POTENTIAL.
OF SKEWS ME FIRE PART -- THREAT
THE POTENTIAL FOR CASTING WHICH
LEADS TO IN EFFECTIVE USE OF
STATE RESOURCES.
AND THERE'S A DECENTRALIZED --
FIRE WEATHER MONITORING WHICH
SLOWS STATE WILDFIRE RESPONSE.
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED SB NINE OH
ONE THAT REQUIRED THE CPC AND
CAL FIRE TO ENTER.
INTO AN M. O. U. TO
COOPERATIVELY DEVELOP CONSISTENT
APPROACHES AND SHARE DATA
RELATED TO FIRE PREVENTION
SAFETY.
IT BUT VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IN
ENERGY DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS
ENSURE RESULTS FROM VARIOUS FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE WILDFIRE
PREDICTION DEFICIENCIES I JUST
MENTIONED SB TWO OR NINE TAKES
THAT COOPERATION REQUIRED IN SB
NINE A ONE ONE STEP FURTHER.
AND BRINGS CAL FIRE DIRECTLY
INTO THE MIX.
UNDER SB TWO OH NINE THE C. W.
W. C. WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ONGOING MONITORING OF FIRE
WEATHER.
FIRE WEATHER IN THREAT
CONDITIONS AS WELL AS ON GOING
IMPROVEMENT OF FIRE WEATHER
FORECASTING MODELS.
THE C. W. W. C. WILL RECEIVE
COURT DATE AND VERIFY
INFORMATION PERTAINING TO
WILDFIRE THREAT CONDITIONS.
UTILITY PROACTIVE DEANNA.
P. URGES ATION OF POWER LINES IN
FIERY VETS THE C. W. W. C. WILL
OVERSEE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
DEPLOYMENT OF A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF AUTOMATED WEATHER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL STATIONS DESIGNED.
TO OBSERVE SMALL SCALE
METEOROLOGICAL PHENOMENA THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO INCREASE WILDFIRE
RISK INCLUDING A STATE WHAT
STATE WIDE FIRE WEATHER
FORECASTING MONITORING AND
THREAT ASSESSMENT SYSTEM.
THE C. W. W. C. WILL WORK WITH
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
ADOPT C. W. W. C. APPROVED
WHETHER MONITORING EQUIPMENT.
AND THE C. W. W. C. WILL OVERSEE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A VALIDATED
FIRE THREAT POTENTIAL INDEX IT
ENSURE THAT EVERY GEOGRAPHIC
AREA IN CALIFORNIA IS COVERED BY
A FIRE THREAT.
POTENTIAL INDEX I'M AWARE THAT
SOME VERY GOOD WORK IS ALREADY
BEING DONE IN THE AREA FIRE
THREAT WEATHER PREDICTION
INCLUDING THE WORK OF ES DE
JEANNIE.
AT OUR OWN CAL FIRE.
IT'S MY INTENTION THAT IN
OFFERING SB TWO OH NINE IS TO
BRING THE DESPERATE FIRE THREAT
PREDICTION ACTIVITIES TOGETHER
TO COORDINATE AND STANDARDIZE
RESPONSE PROTOCOLS. TO THOSE
THREATS BY OUR ELECTRIC
UTILITIES AND LOWER THE
POTENTIAL FOR FUTURE
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S JOHN
KENNEDY I'M WAS RC RC RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA -- WE SUPPORT AS THE
TWO OH NINE AS WAY TO ESTABLISH
A STATE WIDE WILD FIRE WARNING
CENTER RC RC MEMBER COUNTIES
CONTAIN THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
STATE'S FORCE PLANS.
AND WE BORN THE BRUNT OF A LOT
OF THE RECENT CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES AS SUCH.
AND GIVEN THE FREQUENCY AND
DESTRUCTIVENESS OF THOSE FIRES
WERE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
EFFORTS TO REDUCE WILD FIRE RISK
AN INCREASE -- WILD FIRE
RESPONSE.
WE BELIEVE THIS ENHANCED WEATHER
MONITORING SYSTEM WILL HAVE A
NUMBER OF BENEFITS INCLUDING AS
WAS SAID THE PREDICTION OF
WILDFIRE RISKS IMPROVING THE
STATE AND LOCAL ABILITY TO CALL
OUT PRE POSITION ASSETS TO
QUICKLY RESPOND IN THE EVENT TO
WILD FIRE BREAKS OUT.
AND ENABLING UTILITIES TO BE A
LITTLE MORE NIMBLE AND THEY'RE
DE ENERGIES ATION EVENTS WHICH
WE UNDERSTAND ARE INTENDED TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE WILD FIRE
RISK.
HOWEVER IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A NUMBER OF OUR MEMBER
COUNTIES HAD THEIR POWER SHUT
OFF BY P. JEANNIE -- BECAUSE OF
SEVERE WIND WARNINGS -- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT FORTY ONE
CIRCUITS WERE SHUT OFF FACT IN
ROUGHLY SIXTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
OVER A THREE DAY PERIOD IT TOOK
THREE DAYS BEFORE ALL THE
CIRCUITS COULD BE -- TURNED BACK
ON BECAUSE P. GINNY HAD TO GO
OUT AND INSPECT EVERYTHING --
THIS CREATE A NUMBER OF
DIFFICULTIES THAT THE PC IS
CURRENTLY DEALING WITH AND THE
REGULATORY PROCEEDINGS -- BUT
HAD A NUMBER OF IMPACT ON WATER
UTILITIES WASTE WATER DISTRICTS --
AND ESPECIALLY RESIDENTS --
THOSE RESIDENTS IN RURAL AREAS
THAT RELY ON GROUNDWATER WELLS
OFTEN DIDN'T HAVE BACKUP
GENERATORS AND SO THEY DIDN'T
HAVE POWER TO FLUSH TOILETS TAKE
SHOWERS.
UNLESS THEY COULD GO TO A
COMMUNITY CENTER -- OR SOMEWHERE
ELSE TO DO THAT SO WITH THAT IN
MIND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
TWO OH NINE WE HOPE THAT THE
AUTHOR WE CAN WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR IS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
TO TRY AND REDUCE ANY POTENTIAL
AND ON RATE PAYERS -- TO UTILIZE
THE EXISTING NETWORK OF
MONITORING STATIONS THAT ARE OUT
THERE AT THE STATE FEDERAL AND
LOCAL LEVEL AND UTILITY LEVEL
AND DRIVE VOTE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN NOR
WOULD ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT INSURANCE AGENTS AND
BROKERS OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE WHOLESALERS
ASSOCIATION.
ANYTHING THE STATE CAN DO TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF WILDFIRES OR
LOSSES FROM WILDFIRES WILL
BENEFIT THE AFFORDABILITY IN THE
AVAILABILITY OF HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE -- WHICH IS BEGINNING
TO BE AN ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA SO
WITH THAT IN MIND WE'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL INNER DRIVE A
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NORWOOD ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS WOULD LIKE TO ADD
ON ACROSS THE BEHALF OF THE
INSURANCE SERVICES OFFICE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS RHYME FOR
ANY WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ENGAGED -- WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TO ADDRESS A
COUPLE CONCERNS SPECIFICALLY --
SECTION EIGHT SIX SIX NINE POINT
THREE BE -- AS WELL AS EIGHT
THREE EIGHT SIX POINT THREE
THOSE ARE TWO PROVISIONS OR TWO
SECTIONS THE BILL THAT -- WE'VE
IDENTIFIED AS SOME CONCERNS WERE
WORK WITH AUTHORS OFFICE TO
ADDRESS THOSE IN SUPPORT THE
BILL MOVING FORWARD TO CONTINUE
THAT WORK THANK YOU.
THE MORNING CHAMBERS NIGGLING
AND HONEST GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR AS THE GENIE OM ALSO NO
OFFICIAL POSITION BUT WANT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
ON SEVERAL QUESTIONS THAT --
THAT WE SEE IN TERMS OF THE
OPERATIONAL ASPECTS -- AGAIN WE
WANT TO CONTINUE BEING A PARTNER
WITH THE STATE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF'S TIME ON THIS --
MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY SPEAKERS AND UP IN THE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL PULL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
WHO DO THAT AND SEE THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE MOVE BY CENTER PORTANTINO SO
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
AND SEND TO THE ENERGY UTILITIES
AND CONGRESS.
AND WITH THAT PLEASE CALL THEIR
SERVICES DID YOU IS THERE IN
OPPOSITION.
NO I I ASK FOR OPPOSITION OKAY
HEARD.
NINE I'M SORRY I MISSED IT --
MISTER DON I'M -- I THINK IT
WHAT WHAT YOU WANT TO DO HERE IS
GREAT AND FANTASTIC.
I DO I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS --
IN THE THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
AFTER OUR LAST.
A BIG FIRE STORM THE COUNTY --
THE UTILITIES.
THE CITIES THEY ALL.
DID A FANTASTIC JOB OF
COORDINATING AND KIND OF SOLVING
SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS ALREADY
SO I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY HOW.
YOUR PROPOSAL'S GONNA AFFECT --
THAT MY AREA WITH WITH THE
COUNTY ALL THAT SO I NEED TO DO
SOME MORE.
RESEARCH ON THAT I'M GONNA BE A
NO VOTE TODAY.
BUT I'M HOPING THAT -- MOVING
FORWARD.
THE MAYBE I CAN GET AFTER A DO
ALL THAT RESEARCH AND FIND OUT
THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO
NEGATIVELY IMPACT MY AIR THAT I
MIGHT BILL CHANGED TO A NO TO
YES WELL.
I APPRECIATE THAT -- NUMBER ONE
I THINK WHAT SAN DIEGO'S THAT
COUNTY IS DONE IS A MODEL. FOR
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE -- HERE
FOR PARTICULARLY AS D. G. ANY AT
BUT WHAT WE DON'T HAVE AS I SAID
MY IN MY STATEMENT IS WE DON'T
HAVE THAT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
SO I I WOULD LOOK AT THIS IS
DUPLICATIVE WHAT WE WOULD LOOK
AT IS IT'S COOPERATIVE WITH
SANDY -- YOU PARTICULARLY USING
THE CAMERA YOU HAVE THEIR THE
DATA THAT YOU HAVE COMING AND
THE WIND MONITORING STATIONS WE
DO NOT WANT TO HAVE DUPLICATION
AND AND MORE MORE COSTS WE WANT
TO SHARE RESOURCES.
NOT ONLY OF LIKE THE UTILITIES
BUT ALSO THE UC SYSTEM SO THEY
HAVE CAMERAS AND ALL THOSE
THINGS WOULD COME INTO THESE --
WHETHER MOTT MONITORING STATIONS
IT'LL JUST MAKE THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- INCREDIBLY MORE
EFFECTIVE AT DOING WHAT WE NEED
TO DO AND I AGREE WITH YOU ON
THAT AND I YOU KNOW MY CONCERNS
ARE. TO TO TO FOR THE COST
OBVIOUSLY WHICH IS NOT DEFINED.
SO ALL SEAT IN APPROPRIATIONS
AND THEN OF COURSE HOW IT -- I
CAN'T HAVE IT NEGATIVELY IMPACT
THE KEY WHAT THE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO IS ALREADY DOING.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ONE MORE SPEAKER IN THE
BACK.
KIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ALL STATE INSURANCE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO AT THIS
POINT WE HAVE A MOTION TO PASS
AND SEND TO YOU UTILITIES --
TENER.
ENERGY IS UTILIZING COMMERCE AND
WITH THAT CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM ONE SB TWO NINE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD AYE.
DODD AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE ALLEN
AYE ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES. FOR JUST
HIGH BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHANGE.
CHANGE I GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL EYES WEST SO.
WES SO I JONES.
JONES NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO I'D WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE. THIRTEEN TO ONE
THIRTEEN ONE THAT BILL IS EVIL.
THE WHOLE THAT OFTEN OKAY LET'S
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
GO BACK.
FIRST ONE AND THAT WAS THE FIRST.
SO OKAY SO.
NUMBER TWO SB TWO SIXTY FOUR FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO ADD ON FILE
ITEM TO SB TWO SIX FOUR MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
BEAU IS ELEVEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
HI ALLEN HI.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE WEST SO.
WHAT'S SO I NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
WIENER I'D.
SAY ABOUT. FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN
ZERO THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB.
TWO NINETY FILE ITEM THREE SB
TWO NINETY MOTIONS YOU PASS
RULES COMMITTEE BEAU IS THIRTEEN
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
[inaudible]
ALLEN I NIELSEN.
WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER I SO
THAT'S FIFTEENTH ZERO HOURS
FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILLS OUT.
LET'S GO.
BACK TO SB TWO OR NINE ITEM
NUMBER ONE FILE ITEM ONE SB TWO
OH NINE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE.
AB -- IS THIRTEEN ONE ABSENT
MEMBERS NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO. TWENTY THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE THE BILL IS OUT --
THAT CONCLUDES THE THE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTEE IN THIS
MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED